je vous propose de découvrir un petit
bout de loire tourangelle un bout de
loire qui coule devant l'abbaye de
marmoutier une abbaye fondée par saint
martin et qui a rayonné sur la région
pendant près de milan aujourd'hui on va
retrouver un vestige celui de la
chapelle sainte musse est une chapelle
disparu mais dont on retrouve les
fondations grâce au travail et aux
méandres du fleuve loire
il faut s'engager dans le bras qui est
là mais les ruines sont juste là au bout
à sa saga prête
pendant longtemps c'était ici une bande
de terre qu'ils étaient accrochés au
rivage et qu'on appelait l'île de
marmoutier ou belli
alors
donc on est là sur l'emplacement mais il
ya deux ans que je ne suis pas venu ici
je m'aperçois que les crues de la loi
ont tout chamboulé encore les ruines en
1064 quelqu'un a indiqué qu'il y avait
ici une chapelle que leno thoniers
appelait sainte musse est il appelait
sainte luce est pourquoi regarder on
voit bien que ici la rivière creuse
dégage périodiquement ces ruines
et comme si rien n'apparaissait de façon
périodique
on appelait ça pue sets 5-7 7-6 ruiné se
cacher dans le sable et le fait de se
cacher le mot caché en ancien français
se mue s'est donc on appelait sainte
musse est comme si on disait aujourd'hui
sa cachette parce que ces ruines
apparaissaient et disparaissaient
donc ici il ya plein de blocs
ici il y en a un morceau on voudrait
bien que la riviera tout éclater on
connaît bien les moyens appareils et les
pierres du 12e siècle on reconnaît que
c'est du 12e siècle à la taille des
pierres reims et du moyen d'appareils
avec des joints large s est typique de
cette période donc ceci correspond à la
chapelle construite vers 11 123 est béni
par l'évêque gibergues
je me suis aperçu qu'en 1972
tout d'un coup on a prélevé et on voit
là derrière un chenal on a prélevé
beaucoup de sable pour faire des
constructions d'entourer entre autres
l'autoroute a10 on va donc abaisser le
niveau du sol qui était on voit le
sommet du talus là bas le sol était à ce
niveau là on va baisser le niveau du sol
à la recrue suivante la loire va
s'engouffrer dans ce nouveau passage
dans ce nouveau chenal et c'est la loire
qui vers 1972 va découvrir ces ruines
qui était ensablées
on a vu avec cette découverte de la
chapelle sainte plus est que les
prélèvements de sable réalisé par
l'homme pouvait avoir une influence sur
le milieu pour discuter de cette
problématique sable nous sommes avec
clément cirque vous êtes bateliers mais
aussi éducateur à l'environnement
est ce que le sable aujourd'hui
maintenant que les problèmes en sont
interdits sont encore un nom un enjeu
pour nous mais oui il ya déficit
absolument une norme ias on considère
qu'il faudrait huit cents ans pour qu'on
retrouve les niveaux de sable qu'on
avait avant le début de l'exploitation
mécanique donc c'est la denrée
planétaire la plus exploitée avec l'eau
c'est vraiment voilà il ya énormément
d'extraction un peu partout sur la
planète le sable on s'est rendu compte
que il avait une fonction essentielle
dans la rivière c'est le filtre un
filtre c'est le filtre de l'eau puisque
la rivière c'est l'accès à l'eau potable
évidemment aujourd'hui les hommes monde
et des forages les animaux ils vont à la
rivière pour voir et pour que cette eau
soit potable
il faut qu'elles soient filtrées la
rivière elle s'arrête pas à la berge
elle coule à travers le sable est là si
tu creuses très vite tu l'as trouvé
l'eau tu vois de l'eau qu'on pourrait
trouver dans la loi maintenant
bah ouais regarde bien la main tu vas
voir déjà cette eau est fraîche
si on l'analyse est on se rendrait
compte qu'elle est d'un peu meilleure
qualité parce qu'elle est filtrée
mécaniquement et biologiquement donc
voila c'était cool man à travers le
sable est absolument essentielle comment
y faire attention et garder ce
patrimoine fluvial de sable ce qui est
certain c'est qu'il faut arrêter
absolument l'extraction mais même dans
l'image heures parce que quelque part
c'est carrière là ce set aux relations
la laisse comme ça au soleil elle à
s'évaporer le sol wind stocker l'eau
c'est à l'ombre
donc si on veut préserver notre source
d'eau potable mais aussi à londres
merci pour vos explications